[Music]
on this Tuesday night exclusive new
details about a Quebec seniors home
under criminal investigation what
documents obtained by global news reveal
as care homes across Canada are
overwhelmed and many understaffed we
tend to devalue the work of caring for
people 1 premiers plea for more help
Alberta's success in fighting kovat 19
how its response compares to other
provinces and the premiers plan to
circumvent health canada is this china's
chernobyl moment the experts including a
former canadian justice minister
accusing beijing of her coronavirus
coverup and when home is not a safe
place were in a pressure cooker of
stress the troubling rise in domestic
abuse
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
across the country this is a
heart-wrenching time for families with
loved ones in long-term care homes
residents have been dying in their beds
their family members are banned from
visiting in many homes there are not
enough staff to take care of everyone
and all loved ones can do is anxiously
wait for word on where the next outbreak
will be the sad truth is our long-term
care homes are quickly turning into the
front line of the fight against this
virus my top priority right now is
getting the troops and the resources
needed to this front about half the
deaths from kovat 19 in Canada are in
long-term care homes the outbreaks are
worst in Ontario and Quebec where more
than 400 facilities have detected the
virus these are just some of the homes
in each of them at least 20 or more
people have died of Kovach 19 Ontario's
premier says the virus is tearing
through care homes like a wildfire he
vows to do what it takes to save lives
including putting Hospital teams into
infected care homes and doing more
screening and testing of staff and he's
following the lead of BC and Alberta
banning care home staff from working at
more than one facility we'll have more
on the political response in just a
moment but first Mike Armstrong on how
the corona virus is ravaging Canada's
care homes including one that's under
criminal investigation with every day
that passes new nightmare stories
trickle out of this seniors residence
one of the latest from March 29th a
doctor from the local Health Authority
couldn't reach anyone on the phone so
she went in person doctor Ned's in LA
County says she found 130 residents
being cared for by two orderlies and a
single nurse desperate the doctor called
her three teenagers and her husband for
help feeding the residents Kayla Bravo
Beck's premiere Tuesday thanked dr. Lara
and her family for their humanity he
said on behalf of the entire province
now according to documents obtained by
global news from the residences owners
the facility had a sick
nurse on duty showing symptoms in the
days before people started dying on the
29th according to the documents when the
facility was placed under trusteeship by
the local Health Authority only three
patients had died in the two weeks since
even under trusteeship they've lost 29
more as recently as Monday night new
positive tests for kovat 19 was still
coming back now the facility has had
issues in the past a coroner's report
into a residents death last year
questioned the training of the staff the
company that runs the facility says it
provides adequate care as confirmed by
the most recent March 2019 government
inspection the company says public
health officials created a catastrophic
situation when they took over failing to
isolate infected patients and failing to
properly treat and medicate others what
what's becoming increasingly clear is
that even in normal times it is
demanding and difficult work for
employees at care homes to meet the
needs of residents makovan 19 pandemic
is a breaking point close to 300
facilities in Quebec are struggling with
kovat cases about ten kilometers away
this residence has had 26 deaths just
north of that another institution has
lost 33 residents among them Solange
Elsa knew she was 70 years old her wife
and kenton bail calls the situation in
residences immoral this is not something
that just happened by accident they were
never among the institutions that we're
going to get the resources Kenton Beale
says hospitals were prioritized at the
outset of this crisis and rightly so but
now governments have to pivot hospitals
aren't as overwhelmed as predicted while
hundreds of seniors residences across
Canada are they need help it has to
happen yesterday now whether they have
cases or not
seniors residences aren't locked tight
that doesn't only go for visitors but at
times information as well this Toronto
facility has at 25 residents died so I
went for three weeks thinking my father
was fine he's not he's dead the biggest
challenge is staffing employees are
staying away because they're sick or
you're getting sick Quebec is asking
anyone with experience in health care to
come forward and it's talking to Ottawa
about using soldiers in seniors
residences
yeah we're asking them how many people
with the expertise and health care can
be sent to us what has become clear in
this crisis is society's most vulnerable
people were being housed in society's
most vulnerable institutions Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal as Mike
said working in a care home isn't easy
it involves deeply personal tasks like
feeding dressing and personal hygiene
for the residents those who do that work
get low pay and often work part-time in
several homes to make ends meet
Canada's health minister says it is
obvious now that has to change
we tend to devalue the work of caring
for people and I think this is an
opportunity for Canada to actually think
a little bit more about how we will move
forward with a stronger system of care
for people who are aging because in fact
all of us in this room are going to end
up there and these are our mothers and
our fathers and our grandparents and our
aunts and uncles in the short term
though lives need to be saved right now
David akin is looking at what measures
are being looked at and which provinces
are getting it right David well Donna
for most of this crisis the fear was
that hospitals would be overwhelmed and
in fact it is long-term care facilities
across the country that are facing the
most stressed despite our best efforts
we're dealing with a wildfire at our
long-term care homes right now and just
as in Quebec Ontario is desperate to
find more firefighters the nurses and
personal support workers who can help
take care of seniors to that end the
Ontario premier VOAD to redeploy teams
of hospital workers to long term care
facilities will spare no expense to
protect their most vulnerable we must
and we must redeploy every available
resources to our long-term care homes
right now
Onterrio like Quebec is also looking to
boost the pay for part-time workers
looking after seniors and then there's
the rules the protocols that operators
of long-term care facilities must abide
by those rules are set by the provinces
I would say that every province and
territory
really sees with you know doing best
practices so far at least the federal
role has been one of coordination and
information sharing seniors residences
are provincial II mandated but the
federal government has put forward
guidelines for across the country on
making sure that our seniors are
protected those just updated guidelines
incorporate current practice in some
provinces British Columbia's decision
last month for example prohibiting
caregivers from working in more than one
long-term care facility Ontario's
premier said a similar rule would go
into effect in that province overnight I
will say that there are some people
getting it right and it's slow but it's
coming and those improvements could not
come soon enough for Quebec and Ontario
the premiers of both those provinces
today saying that the health and
protection of seniors in long-term care
facilities is now their top public
health priority and it's a concern right
across the country Donna it sure is and
David I want to ask you about something
else an open letter is circulating
signed by politicians and academics from
around the world including a former
Canadian justice minister urban Kotler
it says the pandemic has been caused by
China and it calls it that country's
Chernobyl moment the letter says we
should never forget that China's
Chernobyl moment was a self-inflicted
wound
the CCP silenced Chinese doctors who
wanted to warn other health
professionals during the early stage of
the outbreak David it also criticizes
the World Health Organization claiming
that it bowed to Chinese pressure to
downplay the severity of the situation
have any Canadians besides or when
kotler's signed it well or we call her
was certainly the most prominent name on
that list the former federal Justice
Ministry or long time human rights
activists but there were some other
Canadians there as well authors
commentators academics and this group
has really been trying to sound the
alarm about China for some time but the
Canadian government not ready to join in
on that Krita
system Deputy Prime Minister Christian
Phelan noting that the World Health
Organization gets its information from a
variety of sources she also had some
classified intelligence that she
couldn't talk to us about but there
might be one more reason here and that's
this China right now is a vital source
of the ventilators and masks the Canada
urgently needs Donna all right David
akin in Ottawa thanks
Alberta's premier Jason Kenney is
criticizing the response of Canada's
chief public health officer to the
pandemic Kenny says doctor Teresa Tam
listened to talking points as he calls
them from China and suggests she put too
much faith in the world health
organization Kenny also says he intends
to circumvent Health Canada and will not
wait for it to approve new medications
tests or vaccines for kovat 19 he says
he intends to bring those things into
Alberta as soon as they're approved by
European or American health regulators
this is how Canada's Deputy Prime
Minister responded we have shown that we
are a country that does believe in the
value of expertise and in the value of
science at the federal level I have
observed as a former journalist that
chief public health officers across the
whole country have become this
generations rock stars and that is
entirely appropriate Alberta has
expanded who can be tested for kovat 19
the province believes it now has
capacity to test anyone with a cough or
a runny nose no other province is at the
point of testing that extensively
tonight Heather York's West examines why
Alberta now appears to be ahead of the
curve in its response to kovat 19 as
hospitals around the world scramble to
obtain desperately needed medical
supplies Alberta has been flying in
massive shipments this cargo plane from
China brought more than 36,000 kilograms
of masks gowns and face shields there's
a high level of confidence in the
supplies that we are working with as
well as in the transportation networks
that we have established with some of
the airlines in order to try and bring
those things over the weekend Alberta's
premier announced surplus medical
supplies will be sent to other provinces
in need in the face of this global
pandemic Alberta appears to be in a rare
position well prepared for what's to
come some people they will put in you
know some resources others will say no
we're we're all in and I think I'll
burden we saw early on 2009 2010 and on
that they took approach of all in
endemic planning experts say Alberta's
position is the result of more than a
decade of behind-the-scenes work nearly
every hospital falls under a single
provincial super board and all supplies
are tracked centrally in real-time when
news broke in China in December that
this mysterious viral infection was
spreading Alberta knew exactly what it
needed where it was going to need it
that level of organization may also be
why the province has been able to test
more people per capita than any other
jurisdiction across the country you have
previously heard me say that we were not
able to test every Albertan with a cough
or runny nose but we believe that we may
now be at the point where we can do so
Alberta's response has not been perfect
some frontline doctors who practice
privately have had problems accessing
personal protective equipment
despite the provinces excess supply
there are a lot of physicians out in the
community who are not part of the NHS so
you don't get access still compared to
many other places Alberta is in an
enviable place well-prepared in the face
of a global pandemic that has caught too
many off-guard
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
vulnerable communities in Canada's north
are getting some financial help from the
federal government it will provide a
hundred and thirty million dollars to
help territorial governments maintain
supplies of food medicine and other
essential goods and shore up health and
social services and mandatory
requirements are coming into force
tonight for all travelers and to
entering Canada by land air or sea they
will have to have a credible
self-isolation plan those who don't will
be sent into quarantine for 14 days at a
set location such as a hotel for example
if their plan is to go stay in a place
where there are many elderly family
members at risk of Cove at 19
or whether they don't have a set
destination if they've been outside of
the country for many years we now have
the authority to require them to self
isolate for two weeks in the United
States President Donald Trump has
announced he is halting funding to the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted Trump says the review will
assess what he calls the wh o--'s role
in mismanaging and covering up the
spread of corona virus under his watch
though cases of Kovach 19 in the u.s.
keep rising more than 600,000 people in
the US are now known to have kovat 19
that's an increase of 100,000 in four
days that's only the people who have
been tested more than 25,000 people in
the US have now died from the illness as
Jackson prosecco reports President Trump
says the decision on when to begin
lifting restrictions and restarting the
economy is his alone do you feel you're
as good as you were before this happened
with his country gripped by the virus
u.s. President Donald Trump met kovat 19
patients who'd successfully recovered
they're hopeful stories were quickly
overshadowed by more dark News New York
reached a grim Plateau 778 dead in 24
hours the fatality rate remained
stubbornly high and now the response to
the crisis threatens to be derailed by a
political fight the president wants to
force States to end social distancing
measures sooner than later as he pushes
to restart the economy the authority of
the President of the United States
having to do with the subject we're
talking about his total on Monday Trump
falsely claimed to have absolute power
to and local stay-at-home orders he has
refused to issue a national stay at home
directive of his own the president's
position is just absurd it's not the law
it's not the Constitution we don't have
a king we have a president health
experts have pushed back warning that
now is not the time to ease up this is
not the debate that we ought to be
having this is a public health crisis
we're at the mitigation phase we're
trying to reduce debts in this country
but Trump seems desperate to move away
from talk of the
response eyeing a recovery before
November's election as questions grow
about his handling of the outbreak and
why there wasn't more done to prepare
before the virus grabbed a foothold in
the US and in fact we'll give you a list
what we did in fact part of it was up
there we did a lot you know you're a
fake while all that was going on
California's governor was laying out
what a reopening could look like it
won't be happening anytime soon and will
be phased one example he provided was
restaurants which could see the number
of tables and chairs cut in half servers
in masks and gloves and disposable menus
for the customers Donna all right
Jackson Prosecco in Washington Thanks
coming up strutting her stuff the
Canadian woman bringing smiles to her
street
[Applause]
Russia's president now admits the
coronavirus is going to hit his country
hard
there was talk later Mir Putin's early
moved to shut down most travel from
China plus extensive testing and contact
tracing was succeeding but Putin has
told advisers Russia doesn't have much
to brag about now Russia has hit a new
high of 2,700 confirmed new cases today
more than 21,000 people have now tested
positive and at least 170 Russians have
died
Moscow is hardest hit new hospitals are
being built and lockdown measures are in
place but Russians are being warned to
brace for the worst some lockdown
restrictions are easing in parts of
Italy dozens of small shops and Sicily
and Venice are open but with strict
rules on customer numbers and hygiene
Italy recently recorded its lowest
increase in daily deaths since March
strict physical distancing measures and
lockdown measures - were in place in
Italy's worst hit regions though in
Austria a lot of shops have reopened -
the country hopes to reopen restaurants
and hotels in mid-may if the number of
new infections there remains low ahead
abuse during this pandemic why staying
home is anything but safe for some
people
being told to stay home can be like a
death sentence for those whose home is
not a safe place crisis lines across
Canada are getting a surge in calls
right now from people who need help as
Robyn Gill explains the public health
measures meant to protect lives are
putting some people at even greater risk
in early April Tracie Mackenzie's body
was found in her Nova Scotia home
immediately prosecutors called it a case
of domestic homicide and charged her
partner every five days a woman at
Canada is killed by her abusive partner
we don't know what that's going to be an
under Kovac 19 the stay at home pandemic
measures are forcing Canadians to spend
every hour confined in their homes for
people in abusive relationships it only
further isolates them or in a pressure
cooker of stress right now that
everything that contributes to rates of
domestic violence increasing from
economic downturns to natural disasters
it's all happening calls to crisis lines
are up from victims their children even
the perpetrators asking for help not
everyone will turn to a shelter
there's the dilemma of living in a
communal space with the threat of kovat
19 plus physical distancing measures
issued by public health agencies are
limiting space in these safe havens
violence against women children and
youth is already a significant public
health safety emergency in Canada in
North America and across the world
so the pandemic is just exacerbating an
existing public health and safety
emergency the United Nations is sounding
the alarm on this collateral crisis for
many women and girls the Select looms
largest where they should be safest in
their own homes already there are signs
of a surge in domestic violence in
places where Kovan 19 has a grip the
initial reports coming out of China's
that domestic violence has gone up
threefold there was a report yesterday
that came out of fran saying that their
rates of domestic violence have already
gone up by 30 percent support groups are
asking neighbors and family members to
check in as much as they can to set up
secret signs to let them know they're
okay we do know that increased isolation
you know it just compounds things
extraordinarily Traci Mackenzie's
friends and family only wished she'd
reached out
before it was too late Robin Gill Global
News Vancouver
mrs. dress up next one woman using her
tickle trunk to keep spirits up
hey mr. Potato Head we're all doing what
we can write this New Brunswick woman is
trying to make kids in her neighborhood
smile with some costume changes that be
tingly like everyone else is staying
physically distant from the ones she
loves so she took her tickle trunk to
bring some joy and some laughs to her
community some costumes were a little
more difficult to get into than others
even the Easter Bunny eventually made a
special appearance oh it's good to make
someone else smile especially these days
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Dona Friesen thanks for
watching and take care of yourselves bye
bye
you